wir sind in unseren inhalten einfach
viel zu beliebig geworden ökologische
landwirtschaft soll stärker gefördert
werden als kommunist landwirtschaft die
union keine position der gesetzliche
mindestlohn soll im jahr 2022 erhöht
werden die lokale produktion sorry das
ist nur der anfang
frederik paul liefert klartext das hat
ihnen der cdu schlagartig bekannt
gemacht
alpen am niederrhein sechs wochen nach
der bundestagswahl
hier ist paul aufgewachsen hier sitzt er
für die cdu im gemeinderat zum zustand
der bundes partei hat er in diesen tagen
ein wort es ist einfach nur
[Musik]
also das ist wie gesagt hier mal mein
wahlbezirk den habe ich letzte
kommunalwahl mit 42 prozent gewonnen der
ist bei der bundestagswahl weiter ruht
also sie haben hier einen heftigen
einbruch um stammplätze
wir müssen überlegen was haben wir
eigentlich falsch gemacht
siegessicher war die cdu ins wahljahr
gegangen
und abgestürzt wie noch nie das
schlechteste bundesergebnis in der
parteigeschichte
die macht der kanzlerin hatte jahrelang
inhaltliche lehrstellen übertüncht jetzt
zeigt sich die cdu ist innerlich
ausgezehrt
verstört
die einstigen tonangeber zurückgestutzt
auf opposition
[Musik]
den neuanfang verspricht sich die cdu
mit einem altbekannten
friedrich merz soll ihr parteichef
werden
wir müssen jetzt in der opposition keine
kompromisse mehr machen wir können
zeigen wer wir wirklich sind aber wer
ist die cdu wirklich eine spurensuche in
vier akten
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der ort ist hebt die werte bürgerlich
mitte dezember jahrestreffen der
mittelstands- und
wirtschaftspolitik
der pressesprecher hat geburtstag ein
ständchen muss sein die npd hat rund
25.000 mitglieder viele sind unternehmer
firmenchefs an
diesem tag endet die amtszeit ihres
langjährigen vorsitzenden carsten
linnemann
der galt als parteiinterner kritiker
angela merkel das ende ihrer ära
kommentiert er wie eine art befreiung
man muss einfach sagen auch wenn es weh
tut dass zu viele große entscheidungen
in den letzten zehn jahren aus dem
kanzleramt heraus entschieden wurden und
nicht in der partei vorher diskutiert
wurde die cdu muss konservativer in der
hinsicht werden dass wir wieder haltung
zeigen wir brauchen wieder glasklare
position die unter spiel gegen der
scheinbar kite der cdu zu den anderen
parteien deutlich
digital zugeschaltet roland koch
früherer hessischer ministerpräsident
ikone der besonders konservativen in der
cdu ein gruß aus der vermeintlich guten
alten zeigt das publikum ist sich einig
angela merkel habe die partei entkernt
mit atomausstieg homo-ehe und mit der
einführung des mindestlohns den viele
hier immer noch als weg in den
sozialismus sehen linnemanns
nachfolgerin will jetzt die uhr ein
stück zurück drehen
für die union
muss wirtschaft wieder ein kernthema
werden sonst wird sie keine wahl mehr
gewinnen
carsten linnemann kandidiert jetzt als
stellvertretender bundeschef der cdu und
friedrich merz will dass er künftig die
programmkommission leitet
[Musik]
lehmann soll die zukunft der partei
maßgeblich mit schreiben ist also
wirtschaftsnähe das herz der cdu
[Applaus]
es gibt mitglieder die das völlig anders
sehen
zum beispiel hier in niedersachsen
region cloppenburg cdu-stammland sehr
katholisch geprägt der kreisverband der
cdu macht einen ortsrundgang die
christlich demokratische
arbeitnehmerschaft ist der sozialflügel
der cdu gegenpart zur miete flügel hatte
die partei schon immer im
regierungsalltag hielten sie meist still
macht schweißt zusammen jetzt brechen
die konflikte auf viele hier sind zum
beispiel für 12 euro mindestlohn wie ihn
auch die spd verlangt wenn man sich
vorstellt dass unter zehn millionen
menschen oder arbeitnehmer unter 12 euro
verdienen dann ist es ja wieder
lohnerhöhung dann würde ich als
arbeitnehmer auch die partei will wo ich
weiß ich kann da 12 euro bekommen wenn
ich vorher neun euro 60 habe wir sagen
wir sind die partei der sozialen
marktwirtschaft aber sozial marke
bei uns in der partei nicht erkennbar
also die die ideen aus der partei heraus
und häufig ganz andere dann gibt es
irgendwelche bundestagskandidaten auch
aus der partei die plötzlich die rente
mit 70 fordern das ist einfach nur
neoliberal vielleicht noch aber auf
jeden fall nicht konservativ einer der
lautsprecher der cd a ist ihr vize
bundeschef dennis radtke er ist fest
entschlossen die parteien nicht den
unternehmer freunden zu überlassen und
auch nicht die deutungshoheit was
eigentlich konservativ ist
weil wenn wir auch über würde von arbeit
reden über fragen von gerechter
entlohnung ja entschuldigung das ist
nicht nur kern von katholischer
soziallehre sondern das ist
christdemokratische dna und einfach nur
kopie und praest positionspapieren von
arbeitgeberverbänden zu machen ist
vieles aber keine wirtschaftskompetenz
friedrich merz stand immer für
wirtschaftsnähe sein wunsch
generalsekretär mario czaja ist mitglied
der cdu
das allein dürfte nicht reichen den
identitätskonflikt zu lösen und es ist
nicht der einzige
[Musik]
der ort ist ein symbol
auch wenn die sonne gerade fehlt eine
solaranlagen firma in bremen hier trifft
sich ende november die landes-cdu zum
parteitag an diesem tag speziell zur
klimapolitik
wiege winter ist chef der
cdu-nachwuchsorganisation
in bringen und hat die sogenannte klima
mitgegründet eine gruppierung die die
cdu antreiben will zum kampf gegen die
erdbahn
vom konservativen flügel werfen ihr vor
das profil zu verbessern wie gewinnt
widerspricht
wir stehen vor der größten
herausforderung
von jener partei ein programm wo
drinsteht wie wollen wir diesem problem
entgegen treten und das darf nicht wahr
sein was irgend eine grüne partei
besetzt
im frühling haben wir wie gewinnt das
schon einmal besucht
für sie vielleicht ein paar blumen samen
kein frühling und winter weil mein name
ist gewinnt da und ich kann mir hier für
den deutschen bundestag im september ich
stelle mich mit der aktion ein bisschen
vor weil ich gerne irgendwie als junge
frau unserer heimat vertreten die klima
union war damals frisch gegründet und
winter mit 24 jahren jüngstes mitglied
im cdu-bundesvorstand
ihre mission damals klimaneutralität ins
cdu wahlprogramm schreiben und zwar ab
2040 fünf jahre früher als mittlerweile
von der ampel koalition beschlossen sie
sehen sich nicht in der gefahr in
feigenblatt zu sein
darüber denke ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
nach die gefahr sehe ich auch nicht denn
ich bin ja mit im bundesvorstand und
wenn ich da was sage wird mir zugehört
lieb gewinnt als eine junge
abgeordneten kandidatin vier wochen vor
der wahl stellte unions kanzlerkandidat
ein klima team vor auch wiebke winter
ist dabei co2 neutralität 2040 kommt
trotzdem nicht ins wahlprogramm und
winter mangels wählerstimmen nicht in
den bundestag
jetzt wird also friedrich merz
parteichef auch er klingt in sachen
klimaschutz nicht nach über großem
ehrgeiz
wir sind nach meinem empfinden in den
letzten jahren zu schnell in der
falschen reihenfolge aus kohle
braunkohle und kernenergie ausgestiegen
wir haben jetzt eine große abhängigkeit
von gas vor allem von russischem gas und
wir bestehen gleichzeitig in der großen
transformationen die es in dieser
volkswirtschaft jemals gegeben hat meine
prognose ist sowie das zurzeit von
dieser bundesregierung geplant ist und
vorgesehen ist wird es nicht gehen und
wiebke winter nach der wahl überzeugt
sie immerhin die bremer cdu vom
klimaziel 2040 ein offizieller beschluss
des landesparteitags dafür wird auch ein
schillernder mitstreiter philipp
schröder war deutschland chef beim
elektroautobauer tesla und stand den
grünen nach
jetzt ist er mitglied der cdu wer
demnächst friedrich merz partei
aus meiner sicht in erster linie gewählt
worden ein bisschen sehr pflege für die
cdu auch zu betreiben und ich glaube mit
blick auf die klimapolitik müssen wir
aufpassen dass das richtige für das land
nicht unbedingt deckungsgleich ist mit
dem was die emotionale seele der cdu
jetzt gerade gebraucht hat
bei der energiewende motor sein oder
bremse auch diese frage muss die cdu
erst noch klären
[Musik]
allein schon dass wir den ganzen tag
darüber auf twitter irgendwie
gesprächsthema im politischen bereich
waren wissen erfolg ein coworking space
in berlin prenzlauer berg von hier aus
will der csu-nahen medien aktivist armin
petzschner multi mit seinem team
anschreiben gegen einen vermeintlichen
linken zeitgeist
gegen gender sprache gegen die grünen
gegen china aktivisten gegen einen
angeblichen mainstream die kampagnen
plattform very public pumpt das in die
sozialen kanäle was sie hier für
konservativ halten
tausendfach geklickt auch von cdu
anhängern
eine weitere zielgruppe menschen die
sich abgewandt haben nach rechts außen
es kann im sinne unseres demokratischen
systems nicht das ziel sein dass man
diese leute einfach bei der afg lässt
sondern mussten diesen leuten teilweise
ein angebot machen und sagen
die afg ist klar rechtsradikal aber eure
anliegen migration kritisch sehen oder
sich abgehängt fühlen oder so ist ja
teilweise auch eine kümmererpartei
aufgabe die nehmen wir sehr wohl wahr
und einige in der cdu landen die
plattform toxisch friedrich merz wünscht
dem projekt viel erfolg
ständiges reizthema ist die
flüchtlingspolitik the republic schreibt
von einem sturm auf die eu-außengrenze
von gefährlichem migrationsdruck
für die cdu ist es ein traum der umgang
mit migrationsfragen verunsichert die
partei seit jahren
und diese fragen werden wieder
drängender auch durch flüchtlinge die
über belarus nach deutschland wollen
wenn man sich die bilder an der
polnischen grenze anschaut glaube ich
würde jede
öffnung dieser grenze dazu führen dass
noch mehr menschen kommen und mehr leid
entsteht das heißt ein kurzes hart
bleiben und vielleicht doch eine gewisse
hartherzigkeit so so unerträglich die
für einen individuell auch sein mag wird
am ende des tages dazu dass eigentlich
weniger leid entsteht
[Musik]
nie wieder wir schaffen das nicht alle
in der cdu wollen diese merkel abkehr
[Musik]
schleswig holsteins bildungsministerin
karin prien ist auf schulbesuch sie will
vize chefin werden der bundes cdu
gibt es etwas was sie was sie zusätzlich
brauchen was sie sich wünschen würden so
eine unterstützung die zahl der schüler
und schülerinnen mit
migrationshintergrund steigt abweisend
seien gegen menschen in not um nicht
noch mehr zu locken
für prien passt das nicht in eine partei
die sich christlich nennt
es kann kein ziel von politik sein
hartherzig zu sein trotzdem ist
natürlich die frage ob man sich durch
einen diktator in belarus
erpressen lassen sollte
das ändert aber nichts daran dass man
die menschen nicht an der grenze
erfrieren oder voran lassen darf
friedensmission die partei in der mitte
halten als warnung vor augen hat sie den
weg von konservativen parteien etwa in
österreich
großbritannien den usa
also wenn man jetzt die republikaner in
den vereinigen staaten anschaut dann
würde ich sagen damit haben wir heute
als cdu nicht mehr so schrecklich viel
gemein das und das ist natürlich eine
gefahr und wir müssen aufpassen dass uns
das schicksal nicht auch er alt
[Musik]
wie umgehen mit geflüchteten und wie mit
wählern am ganz rechten rand die fragen
sind nach wie vor ungeklärt und bergen
weiter sprengkraft für die cdu
[Musik]
wiesental im norden brandenburgs die
tierärztin ist unterwegs da es sind
tomatis für die letzte zeit zwischen den
gummistiefel lieblichen absatz nur noch
sabine bruder mischt die landes cdu auf
im sommer hat sie eine
bundestagskandidatur errungen gegen eine
männerriege sie ist ende 30 hat vier
kinder und erfahrung mit alphatier
gehabe
in den bundestag kommen sie nicht trotz
vieler erste stimmen nach der wahl
wollte sie sogar kandidieren für den cdu
bundesvorsitz gegen märz röttgen und
braun als quereinsteigerin
aber sie scheiterte schon am eigenen
kreisverband
neulich jemand zu mir gesagt ein
cdu-mitglied aus meinem wahlkreis
sabine du bist eine bereicherung für
diese partei aber du bist auch eine
kulturelle herausforderung
nach wie vor ist nur ein viertel der cdu
mitgliedschaft weiblich wo das diagnose
ist zweischneidig
viele frauen zeigten zu wenig ehrgeiz
und für viele cdu männer seien politik
immer noch männersache
das verdichtete sich zu einer speziellen
kultur
mir ist in keinem moment in drei jahren
cdu-mitgliedschaft eine straftat
widerfahren aber es gibt eine
umgangsform die macht dass es für frauen
vielleicht unattraktiver ist sich
politisch zu engagieren
und dann sagen demnächst müssen sich
einen nicht antun verbringen sie ihre
zeit mit was anderem
diese schwäche kennt die cdu seit
jahrzehnten und gelobt seit jahrzehnten
besserung ohne großen erfolg ich glaube
dass auf dauer ohne einen größeren
frauenanteil ist alle parteien schwer
haben werden und wir als große
volkspartei müssen da die zeichen der
zeit schon erkennen ich glaube die cdu
muss offener werden für frauen für junge
leute und auch für zuwanderer
wir haben und ich habe die aufgabe
verstanden wenn es um junge frauen geht
die wir mehr einbinden in
führungsverantwortung
gegen eine frauenquote gibt es noch
immer wieder stand sabine bruder ist
dagegen wie gewinner auch sie wollen
keine quotenfrauen sein und meinen
leistung setzt sich durch
so hat früher auch karin prien gedacht
inzwischen glaubt sie ohne quote geht es
einfach nicht
also wenn man das irgendwie 40 jahre
versucht hat und nicht keinen erfolg hat
dann muss man sich andere instrumente
überlegen und wir müssen einfach dafür
sorge tragen dass wir sowas ausfechten
aber daneben auch gemeinsam tragen und
deshalb
werde ich versuchen dazu beitragen
beitragen beizutragen dass das eben
keinen kulturkampf wird in der zukunft
kann sich prien sogar eine doppelspitze
aus frau und mann vorstellen
und friedrich merz zeigt sich
mittlerweile offen für die frauenquote
für mehr nicht eine doppelspitze aus
einer frau und einem mann wie es andere
parteien auch schon seit längerer zeit
haben ist das auch ein modell für die
cdu damit hat die cdu keine erfahrungen
das haben wir nie erprobt und wir haben
uns auch dieses mal zu einem anderen weg
entschieden
zurück zu frederik paul am niederrhein
der kreisvorsitzende der jungen union
bereitet eine video veranstaltung vor
[Musik]
was ich nicht gut finde werne krawatte
also ich weiß ja nicht mal ihr sehen
wollt die herren der schöpfung vom
ringen um den cdu bundesvorsitz hatte er
sich mehr frischen wind erwartet auch
der 66 jährige friedrich merz steht ihm
zu wenig für einen aufbruch
ich bin eigentlich enttäuscht ich bin
enttäuscht weil ich euphorisch war
nachdem die mitglieder das erste mal
wirklich eingebunden worden sind in der
cdu deutschlands bin ich enttäuscht
darüber dass eigentlich zwei dinge und
nicht erfüllt sind bei den kandidaten
personeller und inhaltlicher neuanfang
über wochen neue version wo sind wir
eigentlich in fünf oder zehn jahren und
das fehlt mir vollkommen der ganzen
debatte gerade
die cdu zu beginn des jahres 2022 wirkt
verstört eine organisation am kipp punkt
kann sie kompromiss partei bleiben will
sie es die suche nach neuer identität
hat erst begonnen und sie wird weiter
schmerzhaft sein
[Musik]